[Music]
once the brexit process is concluded and
perhaps the UK has left the EU I don't
know what they're gonna do but whatever
you do is okay with me that's your
decision whatever you're gonna do is
okay with us just make sure we can trade
together that's all that matters
the United States looks forward to
finalizing a great bilateral trade
agreement with the United Kingdom this
is an incredible opportunity for our two
countries and we will seize it fully
we support the decision of the British
people to realize full self-government
and we will see how that goes very
complicated negotiation and not an easy
negotiation that's for sure
that was the president earlier today
reaffirming the United States's
commitment to a strong trade
relationship with post brexit England
join us now with reaction he is the
brexit leader Nigel Farage how are you
my friends good to see you good to see
you here why didn't you come to the
protest with me because I'm hated even
more than Donald and in fact I went into
a building yeah in Westminster earlier
and they found I was there they gathered
outside the protesters oh yeah and I had
to be got out the fire exit out the back
but I've got you a souvenir oh you do
know I do I think it's very important
that we have that absolutely remember
that Trump is guilty at the for climate
change torture that's nothing in the
world by the way you know the 14 states
have record low unemployment's record
low unemployment's for Hispanic
Americans African Americans women in the
workplace oh and we have more jobs
available in America than we have people
to take them that are on unemployment
there's no rationale of this do you know
every one of those people out there are
the same people to go on the anti brexit
marches you know it's just the same crap
so what the president in the Sun
obviously took Theresa made a task yeah
I told her how to do it she didn't do it
right she didn't truth of it is Trump
believes a brexit the whole
administration believes in brexit why
because they believe in nation-states
why because they understand that the
European Union is the epicenter of the
globalist project that's what Hillary
was for
that's what Donald was against that's
what the election was about and you won
by a big margin here we did win by a big
margin but what we've got now a couple
of years on is an establishment fighting
back very hard a very weak prime
minister who doesn't really believe in
what she's doing he says the right thing
it never does it no she says the right
thing does the opposite it's quite
extraordinary that mean they I think
they wind her up at the back in the
morning you know and she out she
robotically robotically says we're
taking back control of our laws borders
and money and it sounds great and then
you see what she doesn't it's different
but I also think this from the early
days of the administration I remember
talking to people around the president
and they were saying to me how excited
they were about a free trade deal with
the UK why because it showed the world
in jeopardy showed the world that
America is not protectionist but it
wants fair trade three and four right
absolutely we promised to America that
we'd facilitate that once BRICS didn't
happen but the agreement may made last
week makes that virtually impossible it
so I the Prime Minister seems to be
hanging by a thread from my observation
yes Boris Johnson big speech coming up
on Monday he have a chance because he
was approached from that I remember oh
look the idea that they're good friends
is nonsense I mean you know Boris didn't
even want Trump to come to London but
yeah times change and there are certain
politicians who can be a little bit
malleable with these things a little bit
yes true run progressive well truth is
Boris did join the brexit party he may
have came late but he didn't he was
important if we had Boris's leader we'd
be in a far better place than we are
batteries in a middle England is in
uproar you support him well I got you
okay
yeah well I'm I am I kind of step back a
bit from frontline politics in Britain
but if they drop the ball and if the
Conservative Party you know sort this
out I'll be back and next time no more
mr. nice guy okay
I'll take that as a yes okay no last
question we listen we love our friends
in Great Britain
we are tied forever I live about 25
seconds yeah we pay 70 plus cents of
every dollar for NATO why won't
step up and why are they making Russia
rich again with energy the whole thing's
a joke and underlying it is a desire to
build a European army a European army
will undermine NATO and I hope Trump if
they don't pay up within the next six
nine months starts to withdraw the
troops and says hey we're serious about
this yeah Nigel good to see you good
pleasure to be back see it sometime here
but I was hanging out with the
protesters what's a great city well
thank you for my good